notre zoom consacré ce soir aux
élections législatives en Italie les
deux grandes coalitions sont données
pratiquement égalité à droite l'Alliance
nationale qui l'une des composantes de
cette coalition obtiendrait à elle seule
20% des voix selon les sondages à cette
tête un homme qui refuse l'étiquette
d'extrême droite même si ces militants
ont repris certains thèmes néo-fachistes
reportage à nos envoyer spéciaux Marie
de La Chaume et marque tout
Georgia a 19 ans elle milite depuis deux
ans d'abord dans son lycée où elle
rejoint une coordination d'étudiants de
droite elle distribue des tracts et
manifeste contre la gauche aujourd'hui
ces références politiques sont celles de
l'Italie fasciste Georgia ne s'en cache
pas moi je crois que qui Mussolini
c'était un bon position c'est-à-dire qui
est tout ce qu'il a fait il a fait pour
l'Italie et on ne le trouve pas ça dans
les pollutions dans les politiques
politiciens qu'on a eu dans le dernier
50 ans un point de vue partagé par 61%
des électeurs de l'Alliance nationale au
début de la campagne électorale Georgia
rejoint les militants du parti post
fasciste de Jane francofini elle dirige
la section des jeunes de la garbatella
un quartier populaire de Rome 40
militants sont sous ses ordres presque
tous des garçons
Georgia vit avec sa mère qu'il a élevé
seul une mère militante depuis 25 ans au
sein du MSI le parti fasciste puis au
côté de l'Alliance nationale
je n'ai pas voulu endoctriner ma fille
parce que je pensais que ceux qui plaît
aux parents ne plaît pas forcément aux
enfants et souvent en réaction face à
cela il vote pour le camp adverse
aucune crainte pour la mère de Georgia
sa fille et elle partage bien les mêmes
opinions anti-communiste anti-avortement
et pour un régime autoritaire ce soir-là
les jeunes de la section organisent un
dîner électoral pour l'Alliance
nationale
issue de la transformation du MSI le
mouvement fasciste l'Alliance nationale
fait partie comme lors des élections de
94 de la large coalition de droite il
aura fallu seulement deux années à son
leader Jane francofini pour faire de son
parti une des trois forces politiques
majeures en Italie officiellement
balayer les chemises noires et les
saluts fascistes l'Alliance nationale se
présente comme le parti de la nouvelle
droite italienne
sélection je l'ai fait parce que j'y
crois et je sais que tous les patients
qui sont ici et plusieurs autres sont y
croient donc si on perdons nous
gagnerons une autre fois
principaux électeurs de l'Alliance
nationale la classe moyenne et les
jeunes des jeunes comme Georgia
nostalgie d'une époque qu'ils n'ont pas
connu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]